The Joe Rogan experience.
There are so many good fighters that are coming out of Dagestan right now and
all technicians.
So it's incredible.
It's incredible.
Whatever's in the water,
they styles too.
Like Zebbie legs up beat style.
Very,
very different than a wrestling heavy style.
Look at this guy.
I met Jesus Christ.
Oh my God.
What a scramble.
So this is a,
I'll do Russia aid Rashid Abdulla Rashim called and said alive.
No,
don't tell me how to say it.
I'll figure it out.
I don't know.
She told her she'd do her.
She had said alive so alive.
And you know what the,
there's a poetic,
uh,
cause him,
there's a poetic nature to the,
to these guys.
I mean,
they're just,
that could be really,
I mean there's simple good people,
right?
They're a,
they're pretty religious and they just kind of,
they don't even believe in fame.
They just believe in excellence.
Well,
you know,
Dan was sort of evident and the mindset behind them was sort of evident at the
end of that fight with Conor where they went crazy and he jumped into the crowd.
He's like,
he's not playing games.
Like he's not,
he's not doing this for Instagram likes or for,
you know,
this is really,
he takes trash talking all this stuff very seriously.
This is all about honor for him.
I think that was kind of upsetting because true.
But,
but don't do that.
Yeah.
And to that,
and uh,
also respect,
I'd hate to say,
but I think there's a certain ethic and honor to the way Conor McGregor carries
himself to all that trash talk.
If you look at the end of the fights,
he's very calm.
He's very kind and respectful and defeat.
And when they guess it's a different culture,
if you compare the Dagestani versus Irish culture is just a different culture
and you have to respect that I think could be,
to be honest,
disrespected Connor's culture as much as of just suspect to Qvc.
I get what you're saying.
But I mean,
when he was done with the fight,
he didn't keep attacking Connor.
It was people in the audience that we're talking shit that were training
partners and motion for as high.
That's,
yeah,
he would,
he had heard that for weeks and he was,
he was done for months.
He was done.
He was like,
fuck you,
I beat his ass.
I'm gonna beat your ass.
And he just said,
I'm not playing games.
And he jumped into the fucking crowd.
I think security could have been handled far better and we'll be in the future
to prevent things like that from happening where people just jumped into the
cage and you know,
I,
but I,
I hate seeing that shit,
but I appreciate where he's coming from.
I mean,
that's who the fuck that guy is,
man.
That's one of the reasons why he's so good as he does have that mindset.
It's one of the reasons,
man,
one of the reasons why he's so relentless.
Like he's not playing games.
He is who he is.
What you see is what you get and what you get as a killer and he's,
he's there smash.
I would've loved to see Conor McGregor versus could be,
it could be before the Mayweather fight,
like,
um,
before Conor [inaudible] gotten,
I think the money makes you less hungry.
Oh for sure.
And do it ain't hungry at all.
I mean,
he's got $100 million,
but I think he still loves to compete,
but there's no hunger anymore.
Like Dan,
no hunger.
I mean,
he might be hungry for success,
but he's,
there's no desperation.
Yeah,
I dunno if that's,
I know what you're saying.
Like he has a lot to lose now too.
It's a different thing.
He enters into a fight with $100 million in the bank.
It's a very different experience than entering into the fight with 1 million and
hoping that you could make three more tonight than,
you know,
like many,
I'm sure fights that he's had in the past.
It's a different world wants whatever he wants forever.
I mean,
once a fighter though is a fighter and that there is an element there that he
still wants glory,
I believe.
Still only 30 yeah,
right.
You still do it.
Yeah.
I mean he's,
I think,
how old's Connor
at the most?
He's like 32 or some shit 30 yeah.
He's young man.
To be set for the rest of your life at 30 is kind of fucking bananas.
And I don't think he's at his peak as a fighter.
So if he just decides who gives a fuck about the money,
I'm just,
I'm here to leave a legacy and I'm going to,
I'm going to just train like a fucking demon and he kicks aside all of the bad
influences and all the distractions in his life and just focuses on training
mean he's a motherfucker,
man.
I mean,
you saw what he did to Aldo.
So what he did to Chad Mendez style,
but he did the Dustin poor.
Yay.
I mean,
he is a bad motherfucker,
period.
I know you're going to shut this down as most fans do,
but if he drops everything and goes to like Siberia to train,
I would love to see him and could be two.
Well,
there's nothing that's my friend Hollins and camp and a con or sparring just
fucking around powerful on it.
Logo in the background.
It's like a Goddamn on it.
And that,
um,
yeah,
I mean he's always going to have a problem with QB.
Could,
bebes.
Wrestling is so high level,
it's so different.
He smothers you in a way that you think you have good takedown defense to.
You run into that motherfucker and he just gets a hold of everyone who does it
to everyone,
whether you're Michael Johnson or Edson Barboza,
no matter how good your take down defense looked in the past and the Barboza
fight,
he was just basically just waited towards him,
waited through the fucking,
the fury of leg kicks and punches and just clamp,
drag,
smash.
And that's what he does to everybody,
man.
Yeah.
The real thing about a guy like him would be seeing a guy like him against a guy
like Jordan burrows.
Like could he do that to a guy who was a spectacular wrestler as well?
Then it becomes me and his striking,
which is gotten very high level.
He's very dangerous striking.
So I dropped Connor.
I mean he can,
he can fuck people up.
He stopped.
Um,
there was some,
he's,
he stopped.
A few people strikes.
He me,
he's dangerous.
He's dangerous enough on the that you would have to,
I don't know how much,
how many really high level grapplers also have like striking that can stand with
them.
Cause if he decided to keep it up,
you'd have an advantage there until they got good at it.
Him versus Ben asking it would be very interesting.
Well,
he would have an advantage and striking over aspirin and a in wrestling.
I don't know.
No big fellow too.
Are they the same way?
No.
Oh,
he's 55 her 70 okay.
Okay.
So I'll ask her and could probably make 55 I mean if you tortured him,
he's got a dad bod though and he's
rude.
No,
he's,
he's proud.
Dad is proud of his body.
I think he was that way in college too.
He was never,
it was never likes Brock Lesnar.
No.
And he was super technical.